today we're going to talk about
something emotional which is
what happens when you go to the doctor
have a basic screening for a test and
you get that letter in the mail saying
you have tested positive for this
disease if you get that letter if you're
anything like me your stomach falls into
your feet and you start to worry a
question that mathematics can help us
answer is
how worried do you really need to be
maybe very worried maybe not at all we
start with the question about what
disease we're talking about is it common
like the flu or is it a rare disease
usually the kinds we're really scared of
some kind of cancer or some unusual
genetic disease maybe something
autoimmune affects a very small fraction
of the population so if it's a rare
disease
and you get a bad result well the second
thing you worry about after how rare is
the disease is how accurate is the test
there are
two possibilities for you either you're
sick or you're healthy and there's two
possibilities for the test it either
says you're sick or it says you're
healthy so you may be sick
or you may be healthy and the test may
say that you're sick or it may say that
you're healthy so if you're sick and the
test says you're sick well for one thing
it's getting it right i think right
should maybe be right in green this is a
true positive and this is a bad state
because you're sick but maybe at least
you've got the disease caught so now you
can begin to treat it another
possibility is that the test says that
you're healthy and in fact you are
healthy so this is a true
negative again that's good news that's
you know that's the best news right but
there are two ways in which the test can
make a mistake it can make a mistake by
telling you if you that you're healthy
when you're sick it's called a false
negative
and there's another case that can happen
which is you're healthy and you're told
you're sick and that thing is called a
false positive so what we've got here is
we've got the correct diagnoses in green
and we've got the false diagnoses the
mistakes that the tests can make we've
got them in red so i want to talk about
when a letter comes in the mail after
you've had this screening for maybe a
rare disease something that's pretty
scary but very remote and you get a
positive result in the mail so you've
tested positive for x i won't name it
too upsetting and uh you wonder what to
do you think well i should call the
undertaker i've got to let my relatives
know this is terrifying i'm now going to
have a dreadful treatment followed by an
untimely death this is i think a very
normal reaction to such a letter and the
question is
do you need to have your day ruined
could be that the test is correct and
you're sick and that's very very sad and
it could be that the test made a mistake
and so the question that you might ask
yourself is
if you were
so inclined mathematically inclined you
might say what is the probability that
i'm sick given that i had a positive
test maybe that's very high maybe 99 and
then you really do have to worry maybe
0.01 percent then you don't need to be
worried how big is that probability
right you've got the bad news so that's
a given for you now and the question is
what's the probability that you're sick
given this information yesterday when
you didn't have this information you
weren't worrying about the disease at
all right there's a remarkable answer to
that question which dates back to the
1700s so
and
more
surprisingly uh then it's so old is that
it was uh brought to us by a
presbyterian minister named thomas bayes
maybe you've heard of bay's rule it has
a way of interchanging what you're
trying to find the probability of and
the given information so i'm going to
write bayes rule for this case and say
that the probability that you're sick
given that you tested positive
is equal to the probability that you
have a positive test given that you're
sick well that's not quite right i just
flip the things over but if you take
this inverted probability and scale it
properly you do get an equality so what
do we do here we say that's times the
probability that you're sick divided by
the probability that you got a positive
test and this is famous bay's rule that
this simple formula was brought to us
you may have learned it in a basic
statistics course or a basic math course
computer science data science
it's a very important
part of statistics
rather
simple to derive in formula as and i
think
hard to absorb in terms of its broad
implications we want to figure out the
probability that we're sick given that
we got this lousy letter and now we've
said that that's equal to something
that's got three things we've got to
fill in so to start brady with what you
asked about the probability that you're
sick let's suppose that it's a rare
disease one in a thousand so i'll say
the probability that you're sick is
0.001 and let's suppose that the test is
really really accurate that when you're
sick it catches it so just to make this
totally simple i'm going to say suppose
the positive test given that you're sick
if you were sick it would catch it a
hundred percent of the time now most
tests aren't quite that good but a lot
of them are really good like 0.99 or
0.98 so my simplification here is not so
far off and then what we've got to do is
stick something in the bottom here
what's the probability that you're going
to get a positive test probability of a
positive test has got two parts to it
one of them is the probability that
you've got a positive test given that
you're you're
sick and
one of them is that you've got a
positive test given that you're healthy
that's those false positives now this
isn't quite right the way i've written
it because it's here i've just added up
the positive test given that you're sick
and the positive test given that you're
healthy but i need to scale those
numbers by who they apply to now we've
said that the probability of a positive
test given
that you're sick is one but we know that
the probability that you're sick is very
small so that's going to make only the
tiniest tiniest contribution so we have
a 1 here for the positive test that
you're sick 0.001 for the probability
that you're sick then there's the
positive test given that you're healthy
times the probability that you're
healthy that's a very big number 0.99
now what about this positive test given
that you're healthy we go over here
that's the red that's our false
positives and let's suppose this is a
pretty good test that it's going to tell
nine healthy people that they're healthy
and one healthy person that he's sick
out of every ten so it might catch all
of the disease but it also might tell a
few healthy people that they're sick as
well so this goes back over to this box
there's two ways to make a mistake it
can still make mistakes by telling
healthy people that they're sick and i'm
worried that in this particular test
that that happens in one out of ten so
the probability of a positive test well
this number because of that rarity of
the disease is effectively zero and this
number over here is effectively 0.1 so
this is very close to 0.1 so i'm going
to put that point one here and say that
now i've computed that the probability
that you're sick given a positive test
is effectively one
times one in a thousand divided by one
over ten and this is one in a hundred so
how worried should you be when you get
that bad letter well if the test is
virtually all the time right when you're
sick if it makes a one in ten rate of
false positives and it's relatively rare
affects only one in a thousand in the
overall population that's called the
base rate then your chances of being
sick are one in a hundred
now
seems a little premature to call the uh
the funeral home i would think
applications so we can do the exact same
analysis uh in the case of somebody
who's uh trying to identify criminals in
lineups right criminals are a small part
of our population at least we hope so i
think they seem to be you have forced
monty's hand he knows where the one
remaining goat is he knows it
and he has to show it to you